I like this place and I'm starting to
believe this is where I'm supposed to be
the mafia there's like cancer no cure
nine seconds that's what I'll give you
to decide your fate
I'll leave this place like a war blew
through it I'll be waiting for you hurry
up five four
you're warning me I'm preparing you
three two
The Equalizer three coming soon you like
being in other people's business I'm
trying to wear hard not to be you make
it very challenging for me are you
warning me that's the median nerve that
I'm compressing on a scale one to ten
that's a two that's a three
you don't want me to go to four
all the mafia will come to destroy you
I'll be waiting for you The Equalizer
three coming soon in cinemas because of
these people I'm beginning to understand
real peace
whatever it is that you and your friends
do it somewhere else you have nine
seconds to decide your face
all the mafia will come to destroy you
hurry up
the mafia there's like cancer
nine seconds to decide your faith
how late this place like a war blow
through it I'll be waiting for you hurry
up let me equalizer three only in
cinemas